actually you won't know this people
watching but during every show once you
finish the show as a little gift from
Joe to you it gives you a signed copy of
Minecart and this hat we got it from him
yeah he gave it to me speaking of the
Jews the Jews the Jews turns out Joe
Rogan hates us mate does he yeah
apparently but the internet says Joe
Rogan's massively anti-semitic hates the
Jews yeah uh because he said this Anton
let's play the clip and find out why Joe
Rogan hates the Jews so yeah the idea
that Jewish people are not into money is
ridiculous listen that's like saying
Italians aren't into Pizza
listen it's [__] stupid I understand
that the way she phrased it like she
could have phrased it a different way so
that people would have less of a freak
out but can you not talk about the
influence of money in DC I mean you know
the
yeah if you say that there's any truth
to the idea that uh Jews Like Money that
The Stereotype exists for any sort of
reason you must hate the Jews mate I
think that's the only logical
explanation and Joe is is obviously a
massively hateful guy yeah I know and he
hates everyone of course he hates
actually that's why he keeps having Jews
on the show because he hates them that
much yeah and that's why he's best mates
with Irish Affair that famous non-jewish
sounded non-jewish looking comedian I
mean there is nothing Jewish about Ari
in any shape do you not do a show called
Jude yeah I mean he might have done mate
but you know this is you know this is
circumstantial evidence right
inkstensors do you like money okay
I mean obviously yeah of course she does
of course I do you know that have you
seen Scrooge mcdark at the start of
DuckTales where he's diving into gold
coins that's me yeah that's his right
back that's me without the money exactly
right when I have money that's what I'm
gonna do I don't know to send the Super
Chat send the paypals we're going to
talk about all of that but yeah mate uh
Joe Rogan hates the Jews do you remember
how he was really nice to me when we met
yeah he was he was very I thought four
two nights yeah well I think that's
evidence that he hates the juice exactly
clearly because you know this and we
need to we need to call out this type of
vile anti-Semitism exactly when a
comedian makes an off the cuff quip yes
on a podcast or a show where he talks
for literally hours every week it's
really important that what we do as a
society is we clip a little bit
completely out of context exactly make
it gold viral yes and then we then did
finish straight destroy and must be
destroyed he hates the Jaws
exactly and then we're in his entire
reputation and it doesn't matter his
previous Behavior contact or who he who
he talks to or who his friends are he
clearly hates him yeah but he talks to
different people mate they have
different opinions and that clearly
means he hates people yeah exactly he's
a hateful guy I mean clearly if you
watch his content you can tell he hates
the Jews I mean he had Kanye on about
what three years ago two years ago and
he didn't know that Kanye was
anti-semitic at the time but he did have
him on yeah and since then it turned out
that Kanye was anti-semitic yeah which
means Joe Rogan his personal responsible
in fact I reckon he made them
anti-semitic absolutely that's what
happened Kanye went on Joe Rogan's show
and they just had a chat about music and
stuff yeah and then he became he started
hating the juice and no what actually
happened mate is they were talking about
hip hop and Joe went yo this is all well
and good right but have you ever read
mind Camp exactly just slid it across
the table Yeah and then they clip that
bit out yeah and then they Kanye read it
and lo and behold before you know it is
on Alex Jones's it so with a shock over
it exactly this is how these and where
do you learn that from Joe Rogan yeah
because that that's what Joe does that's
what he does actually you won't know
this people watching but during every
show once you finish the show as a
little gift from Joe to you it gives you
a signed copy of Minecart and this how
we got it from him yeah he gave it to me
yeah exactly he was wandering around the
street he's like you're Jewish you'd
like one of these wouldn't you yeah yeah
and you you that is what happened he was
walking around the streets of Austin
wearing a Nazi cap with a copy of mine
hit Liz and the pair of goose March I
mean he's quite sure for the goose March
he still does it though exactly so look
and it's important that we call out this
Behavior it is I mean if we do not call
out a comedian on a podcast making an
off-the-cuff remark about a stereotype
that exists about Jewish people for very
good reasons if we do not do that then
the Holocaust in fact it's all it's
happening right now I can feel it yeah
it's gonna come back mate yeah I mean I
can already feel it I can feel as a Jew
I can feel the Holocaust coming back
because Joe Rogan made a comment on his
podcast exactly I mean that is what's
happening and really what's what's
really important about this entire thing
is that we talk about it endlessly on
Twitter we smear a man's reputation yes
and ultimately it achieves nothing and
in a week excuse me what do you mean it
achieves nothing
what do you mean we're stopping the
Holocaust oh yeah that's a good point
the Holocaust was about to happen
because of what Joe said yeah and if we
call him out on Twitter then the
Holocaust will be stopped that is true I
mean that is how it works yeah have you
not seen Schindler's List no it's
basically a movie about someone not
being called out on Twitter enough and
things get out of hand yeah I mean oh
yeah I said that's what happened I stand
corrected because that is what needs to
happen in fact I think the only reason
that the Holocaust did happen is that
Twitter wasn't in existence right in the
1940s and also not enough people called
Hitler out in newspapers and that yeah
because if you do that if you call
someone racist that solves the problem
yeah I mean to be honest with you I
think Hitler was pretty honest about his
races exactly I mean he wasn't hiding it
just like Joe Rogan exactly
it's not as if Hitler was just like you
know what uh it's not into dubious come
I mean say what you like about Hitler
mate but when it comes to the Jews he
was pretty forceful exactly look I think
we've saved the world here mate
absolutely we've had this chat and now
the problem solved isn't it absolutely
every dude can rest safely in their bed
with their money exactly fantastic
exactly well I do that if I had money
but not enough for you